greetings you bad [ __ ] it's
Monday the 9th of March hold on one
second you can't stop Monday off for
another [ __ ] bong it greetings
from podcast Ville today in studio or
whether the [ __ ] we call this the bat
cave is my main man mr. Brian Redman
stop uncle Joey you got the Christ
killer here on my side looking good
still [ __ ] coughing what do you know
he's got the [ __ ] thousand month
coughs this book best I have that yeah
the dry coffee never ends I don't know
whenever I get a little bit of ends when
you know these [ __ ] no it doesn't
then it goes away you have any nobody
snatch in a year for more you have any
nobodies [ __ ] and the [ __ ] a year
where was that at the strip club
I didn't eat an [ __ ] the strip club
yeah no you lick the [ __ ] night which
is right now I'm surprised you're not
angry and this is in the room with
Chinese people looking at each other it
is freaky traveling right now I was in
Vancouver and man like the plane was
half Chinese those places next week I go
right into the zone I gotta go to LAX
that zone number one hot spot more
[ __ ] Chinese people crawl up through
there in Canada wait till it starts bred
in Canada and I'm not racist to Chinese
I'm just telling you what the [ __ ]
going on these people bring it in from
planes yeah I knew would be from planes
it's easy
that's the quickness but I gotta go to
JetBlue Kennedy and back that's five and
a half hours of sitting there that
radiation yeah you know you come off the
[ __ ] plane you clone in the [ __ ]
dark so I take my life into my hands
next week for this but guess what after
that I don't have to get on a plane
again toes first in May so I got a long
time to this nor April 17th and 18th and
Reno I'm gonna take jeddaks
because his wife walk around for the
extra 50 bucks
and then from Reno to Portland I'll take
whatever and then Portland out to fly
into Burbank and then we'll figure out
if it's worth water accent not if it's
not we can't so every day on how I act
is not in you to do
yeah nothing you could do I had the mask
on you gotta get the mass in the kills
my age yeah
it's killer that's right they call for
me do I have ready Tory problems listen
to my heavy breathing I'm the perfect
[ __ ] candidates Ron I can't that's it
I'll end this whole [ __ ] territory
day and it's a reality but reality that
might spread by the summer and might
they say it ends in April and they'll
pick back up and September when it gets
cold in October and then you know who
the [ __ ] knows but we don't really know
nothing people coming in then I getting
tested they're saying that they wanna
news ain't nobody said boo to me I am
sweating bullets and [ __ ] my eyes are
dilated nobody even looked into my eyes
but in the hypnotist
there's nobody nothing nothing a swab
are you talking nothing well even before
the coronavirus there's always someone
sick on a plane oh there's only oh the
[ __ ] that's why I take those JetBlue
seats so low there's a reason there's a
reason if I have to go to East Coast I'm
not sitting somebody cuz you always get
bad luck I always get battle syphilis
when I want to play many nobody I want
to talk to that sits nice to me
have you want someone older woman that's
married you could talk to them because
they know you don't want no action so
nobody's hit on this [ __ ] old back 50
[ __ ] years you know they know you
just talking to uh make way oh we do for
a living I tell them you know undercover
DEA never told I'm a comic
and then sometimes they're like wait a
sec I've seen you in a movie then they
got me that time
I'm always undercover DEA the worst
memory no I tell them right off the bat
and then someone came up to me and [ __ ]
my [ __ ] up hey Joey we love you I'm
Rogan goddamnit on the coven again be no
[ __ ] family
what's up Brian read-back not much
it is weird like those planes do you
think they spray them down anybody
nothing nothing how many times have you
sat there and seen 20 nationalities off
a plane and within two minutes they're
like warning a one you got to get
somebody in there with a can of Lysol
will Lysol spray the plane you know get
people wipe the planes now this part of
the airline's industry this is where
we're getting [ __ ] [ __ ] and he
asked for years I've been saying that we
think that now I've been handy wiping
those planes my wife told me about this
three years ago I got on a plane when
everybody's seating I wiped my seat down
the handle that tray your hands again
especially if you're a window guy cuz
I'm gonna call the guy that's always
leaning my cheek on the window and such
the doorknobs and so far I don't know
how people touch a doorknob it's the
most disgusting [ __ ] thing in the
world
yeah you know I don't touch a [ __ ]
doorknob I used my sweater yes again
keep going to 7-eleven I'm pushing that
a handle that's the first place you're
gonna get it you know 7-eleven those
places so you also have to be
conscientious you gotta wash your
[ __ ] hands listen I love you to death
Brian I'm not smoking enjoying with you
that's true too
especially you like you go to you're on
the road smoking with all these fans and
stuff that's never gonna happen
it killed Ralphie Mac because he got
that bronchitis and thankfully if you
got bronchitis and you had to fly the
travel every time you got on that plane
history I was a far and [ __ ] going
into your weakened immunity weakened
immunity once I hear a call the plane
ride gets canceled
it's not worth I'd rather can't why why
would I go the Columbus Ohio perform
sick and coughing and tearing they don't
want to see that Joey Diaz and I don't
want them to see that Joey Diaz will do
it next night when it's now flu season
we [ __ ] up sorry yeah yeah you're
hundreds all right you know listen the
reason why the flu gets spread any many
times I love
not even my daughter and the kid next to
a little [ __ ]
and then there you go it's also arity
seasons really bad my are DS killing
only sneezes I open up a call with ya
whether it's allergies chin chin juice
whatever the [ __ ] it is I'm at The
Comedy Store somebody sneezes I move out
of the [ __ ] area you know there's a
thousand things you know now you're a
commie strong finger pump Tuesday nights
half of them and immigrants they just
came through whatever point you god
knows you got a plane the pump and no
hugs listen yeah we're going up straight
up gangstas we're doing pictures with
far less you got a [ __ ] body Surat
got like horns like if you're gonna hunt
the bees you know those guys and when
the bats is [ __ ] with the white suit we
need to start wearing gloves again like
like isotoners remember having ISOTONER
who it's really good like [ __ ] why
aren't we wearing globey says oj [ __ ]
you walk around with gloves couple
months ago you a lot of people
celebrated you are being the pod father
and I stick it about and I'm like you
know I stir them but busting your balls
when you and Joe will go up to the room
and bust my balls like come on come up
to the room and do a podcast me oh yeah
a cop who's up at 14 years old who's up
at midnight a bunch of 14 year olds and
you guys would smoke could I lose my
mind yeah you didn't you hated it I
remember you close that close turn that
camera you want to give them the
evidence to come in Angus yeah we they
legal DC smoking chimneys mmm they gonna
say is and then somebody called Joe's
management said that they kid did DMT
because he watch was a pile of [ __ ] no
you know no I don't remember that so all
that talk had it go away like all this
was [ __ ] like I stir them weren't
going down then you guys started doing
it on a couch don't pop up from time to
time of us see ya together on a couch
weird me next to Ari with hair with a
t-shirt I think eventually there's gonna
be like a history book written about it
cuz those early podcasts like the
fleshlight days of the Joe Rogan podcast
are why I'm here that's how I find all
you guys those podcasts are legendary
some of them don't hold up weather
though they're like an old movie where
you sit back and watch and we're
bitching at about something like you
know some crazy conspiracy like aids
isn't real and you're like what the [ __ ]
are we talking about yeah I miss those
days
it's funny what my pops up on my screen
once a month every time I open up
YouTube and let's say I'm scrolling for
a certain but like the first home page
one thing always pops up that I go WOW
and it's like a nice hot box from The
Chronicle mm one popped up about ten
days ago
I am [ __ ] high and it was right
around the time my wife was pregnant
when I said I had to go home cuz I got a
pregnant wife I watched that weird it's
like a time capsule there had to be
seven of us in that room barking into a
microphone rogue in me you I watched the
one with Doug Stanhope call me Joey
jingles and I was dying and then I did
one with me Stan oh yeah and you got mad
about I remembered it you've met yep I'm
not sure yet take her money I didn't do
if I did it I did it then but the reason
I adore Stanhope on Rogan is because I
hang them on to light cigarettes oh yeah
like I'll pull them on the sign alyssum
Rogan loves when you smoke and he loves
to smell the cigarette smoke and don't
say I hope you look at me going like
you're [ __ ] crazy
he doesn't like cigarettes yes he does
he just don't like telling people
because every time like Stan I'll take
my cigarette out we talk a lot go talk
to Joe like this for a minute then he
goes every time he does that noise
Joseph I would jump a little bit and I
would [ __ ] die
because I know it's eating the way Joe
every time you here and isn't that crazy
early episodes we're in Joe's house and
we're lighting up cigarettes inside his
house you know how insane that sounds to
a date we were smoking cigarettes and
Rogen's house hid in his office oh my
god look at what this is [ __ ] become
it's insane it when you sit back and
look at the years and the big podcast I
was supposed to be big and disappeared
and the concept podcast but still this
is what America still wants to hear is
the basic what's happening into your
conversation podcast you know just three
people tube guys talking [ __ ] you know I
love when people contact you and say hey
this cat would be perfect on your
podcast you know I came over got a
million [ __ ] downloads because I've
known them for 20 years and that comes
true over the microphone people feel the
love you know when I go on rogue you
know I'm like this dumbest guest I don't
know I've been on there a lot and I get
[ __ ] boy hits little geniuses like
genius is the glasses don't let my
biochemist yeah and you gotta read the
post to those I love with Joe as
scientific ecologist on you're a [ __ ]
dummy you know that you try you're
probably sitting there with your glasses
I've got 20/20 vision you just want
people to think you're smart it it's so
weird that I go on there because we're
not saying nothing that they haven't
heard already they feel the love going
through the microphone they feel this
guy really cares for this guy well
Ralphie would come on in here you know
when you come on here when Eddie comes
on here they feel that those podcasts we
get great numbers because we would you
sit here and um I was like to eat two
garlic pills but last night so you gotta
watch out for those things right they
make me burp in like non-stop oh they
don't make me that clean
cleaning Faro to me for eight hours I'd
rather for this rather it could go out
and to me go in it's not purple [ __ ]
thing you know what that was like the
hot restaurant like the worst restaurant
the garlic one garlic one it is it's
stinking rose yeah just but it's got to
be an outside patio I'll go there next
time I don't cause I don't want last
time I left there on paper it's a great
wrestler really is from the minute you
get to they give you a huge piece of
bread with a roasted garlic and you
squeeze the garlic close up it's better
than [ __ ] about it it's better than
mother
you sit there come on how could this be
and then you get everything [ __ ] it
yeah that place is great but no watching
those early that's ten years ago more so
it's even longer now some of those are
like when me you and that one dude used
to do it like like would just be like in
the van I'd like somewhere here in North
Hollywood go get some food and put a mp3
recorder down in between us aw you know
remember when we used to do you don't
rightly remember like where we used to
read just record at a restaurant and
like there's a picture of us like
outside in parking lot doing a podcast
with a little mp3 recorder but I don't
me you and Hari my steps talking about
cats cats right yes
my cats are cats you know you think
about all this [ __ ] you know wow it's
like we was doing common who opened my
crews yeah a podcast said we were open
bankers that was our first five years we
did crazy this we did live podcast I
mean you guys have turned killed Tony
into a [ __ ] rats and then yeah huge
monster now I've watched killed Tony
sometimes and I die laughter but I'm
also watching what you guys are taught
international and I pay what pisses me
off that not even truTV has reached out
oh yeah it's it's this is a show that is
could be [ __ ] enormous I think
there's kind of scared of it because
when it's one of the last shows that I
think is still raw and like there's like
there's nothing peace
about it like we actually lean against
it you know it's and I think you know
they look at them like well there's a
reason for the internet because this
show you know that we can I mean know
that let's get let's get milking that
company involved in Monday night you pay
per view it and you really have real be
a like a great real opinions and say you
know what go shoot yourself I mean you
know people want to see that guy that's
got the balls to tell a young comic to
shoot down his dream I don't have the
balls to tell the comic to shoot down
his dreams I'd say something whatever
but had a positive no mm-hmm and always
have a positive note I don't have the
balls to tell somebody especially
nowadays you don't know who you're
talking to we got that purse house
murderer on last month so you don't know
it like half these people you know I'm
the bot a do or die
I think well I think about kill Tony
sometimes I think about the people who
used to say that [ __ ] to me
when I first started saying calm and I
gotta tell you something
70% of feedback they would say something
to me but it would always be by they
gonna lose that joke that hurts that
hurts when you [ __ ] stay up one day
and you think the joke is good and it is
a good joke you just said in the wrong
place and it ain't such a bag of dicks
that the guy you're working with is like
just get rid of that joke and that that
hurts you know like that hurts nobody
wants to hear that but there's certain
people that I've known for 20 years that
we should just put on kill Tony just to
tell them why they've been here for 20
years
oh yeah has happened yeah and we get
that to some of these guys we've been
doing comedy for 20 years and you're
like what the hell this is what happened
yeah you know that joke you do you never
got rid of it yep you never got rid of
it you know when you don't come how told
him yesterday you first found four years
what do you think you're writing for a
special just write and get on stage
every night that's it this is a just get
over those three we're finally people
start I'm seeing in clubs now
you know we're not hard to copy here
then it's not like there's a shortage of
comics here right you know everybody's
chasing the same [ __ ] nickel when
you're in LA so the only one a gold one
that comes to be creative you got to be
creative and also and find that [ __ ]
way but it's three or four [ __ ] years
you know I I don't know I just always
felt killed Tony should be on TV HBO I
agree
Friday it's a TV show I even feels like
a TV show when we're doing it I could
see it and I watch it I'm like this is a
TV show have you not thought about doing
like a tournament nationwide or
something like best uh or what the yeah
Cassius Morra showed up oh yeah he came
I was so upset that he didn't go on
because I would loved there's a few
people like like last night dumbfounded
I don't know if you know dumbfounded
Jonathan Park he put his name in the
bucket I was like oh man I would love
this I've seen you know somebody that I
love as a rapper do one minute on kill
Tony and then you had Casius we've we've
known since what you was 14
I would love to have seen him that's the
only bad thing about it I wish out to
you although I knew he was there but
that you know the whole thing is it's a
bucket bug you know like and there's
been so many times where I'm like maybe
we could just bend the rules but then
that defeats the purpose
yeah and I tell you some of these shows
you go to the middle of nowhere and
these people are like never done comedy
before never want to do comedy they just
our fan they want to sign up and then
it's just like and they want to give
people to say shut up
well we yeah we just want people to
actually only sign up if you want to
actually try to do comedy not just
because you're a fan and you just want
to be on stage you know because then it
becomes like a any gross bars show in
Myrtle Beach or something like that you
know like it's that's there's negatives
parties but when it works it works when
that when that buckets
you know sometimes that buckets amazing
with the [ __ ] that comes out of it you
know it's for you guys did this and I've
been just talking about this recently I
mentioned it to Lee how you got status
in comedy 30 years ago well I gotta have
to come it is very simple nobody was the
other way special except HBO and showed
I'm once in awhile and if you all show
time we'll offer you special I think you
took it when you called HBO and said
this is your last chance right yes is
your last chance I'm threatening you
show time show times got my back you
know the only way you got ahead the only
way you got ahead was with the Johnny
Walker red competition comedy
competition which was nationwide HBO had
a national competition which was
nationwide and I did the best comedy
competition the rocky mountain edition
so they had in California the Rocky
Mountains Iowa Chicago in New York they
would do six cities and then we were
supposed to do a national champion but
then Beck's just said we'll do that next
year I don't think they would did yeah
the only bad thing about the contest
part Dini start feeling like all the
other shows like America's Got Talent or
Idol or whatever and [ __ ] like that
so what we do is we give out the golden
ticket so if we find somebody in a city
and they're just so freaking amazing
we get my golden ticket meaning anytime
we're in that city or any time anywhere
near you get to go up automatically if
you come to the show and a lot of these
people come to LA and then they get you
know hey we got a golden ticket winner
here you might remember her from Alabama
you know blah blah blah so that's kind
of cool because we actually have was
starting like a little gang of comics
that a preacher loss and I don't have
you know preacher loss and he you know
before it blew the [ __ ] up he used to be
on kill Tony it was like almost like a
golden ticket winner we're like we kept
on having him on and just Washington
amazing he's amazing I love crazy yeah
he's he's like one of the nicest people
ever you know he's great but yeah it's
it's interesting seeing that happen you
know this is the best thing you caught
on to this is it's fine and it combines
guys make it fun yeah like [ __ ]
Jeremiah
God is what will you do it's a psycho
you will it's amazing being on the road
with him a it's so weird when you go on
the road
and you get to see the real him you know
the real person like who would ever
think Jeremiah would be the person I
would bring empty water bottles and it's
filling up his water bottles everywhere
he goes and you know he's very
particular with everything out there
it's it's fun being on the road with
some of these guys I don't know what
happened I just saw a video on Instagram
Joel the drummer who's the nicest guy
possibly in the universe was running
around at your show with like a strap-on
dildo yeah people challenged him for so
our drummer amazing drummer he you know
he's sponsored by one of the biggest
drum companies ever he if we find out
somebody that's pulled out of the bucket
I knows how to play drums and if they
other play drums good we have a
competition where he whoever that guy is
and Joel they'll have a drum off and if
the guy if the crowd votes the the guy
better at drums then that guy gets
Joel's job in and he's not working for
us and Joel has to just quit you know
and so it did joel has to fight for his
life on the drums these some of these
people are like dude I've been playing
drums for 40 years you know like I'm the
best drummer ever and Joel's in the back
sweating like trying to put on a costume
cuz hit like Joel the only reason Joel's
one he's like undefeated is that he
makes it a show like he puts on a
strap-on dildo while the guys playing
you know he takes off as sure he does
back flips and stuff like he's just
selling it you know or the other guys
just like you know how they without
power so yeah it was midgets the only
way the only who is there's bleacher
people like a little guy and yeah
they're there once a week on us come on
yeah yeah
so that show doesn't exist anymore I
don't I think it might I don't I know
they loved Rob Kelly mmm Tripoli Khalid
like they loved and we see them in their
way Joe called me
who else with Jeff Ross I always see
they always come to hang out Johnny yeah
that was a crazy time of Vegas and
that's what you guys have had you've had
a little bit of that it's like circus
tease away meets [ __ ] like gong show
on Roscoe meets [ __ ] real comic
meets its it's gonna to be a TV shows
yeah
and it's great because it's the show we
could take it anywhere you know like and
it's it it works anywhere you know like
we've even gone overseas to like
Australia Europe Ireland and it makes
all the shows of England yeah yeah we
were in English we all yeah we all had
food poisoning I saw that show and I was
blown away it was a theatre yeah
it was a [ __ ] theater internationally
yeah so I was like Jesus Christ this is
this is either you guys have to do a
show or the best of every city around
the world and making a theatrical
release movie like [ __ ] Impractical
Jokers I'm not blowing smoke I know I
agree I'm not into if I don't think it's
a good idea it's just getting like a
camera crew you gotta fly them yeah
that's really Iceland comes
we've had some talks with some companies
already and you know they of course the
only thing that kind of sucks is they
still want to change little things and
it's like nowadays with YouTube and and
and you know podcasts of stuff it's like
how much do you need these guys anymore
to make it a show when we just put up
three this week that's the only thing
that's nowadays it's not so cut and dry
anymore
where it's like hey dude you were giving
you you know thing on Hulu you know what
I would love is them just to repeat our
[ __ ] on Hulu maybe up our production a
little you know our cameras and stuff
like that but just take our product and
just replay it instead of you know like
what we're selling it to them kind of
like how you do it like how you'd make a
special then you sold it to what didn't
you do that like oh oh somebody did that
I forget who it was they just make their
own specials and then sell them I forget
I thought it you did John
yeah Joe does that right yeah so that's
the way to do it
you make the product if you want it you
buy it if you don't get out of here
because I'd like like every TV show or
every Hollywood things like well you
know we think we need to have you know
behind-the-scenes featurette of this and
that and I'm like
that's not the show no one wants to see
like this American Idol like you know
John was born in lbm I know a couple
[ __ ] people slip yeah
and the one guy shows up and does
edibles right like this also gotta be
three guys you slip edibles - I had this
great idea and I wish Tony Tony did not
like it but I had this idea cuz you know
the popularity of hot ones and stuff
where people are eating hot [ __ ] on the
internet I mean any video on YouTube is
somebody eating up hot pepper like I had
this idea where I would bring something
super spicy every week and if anyone
wants to eat the spicy thing you get to
do two minutes but you have to do it
right after you eat it so I got this
chocolate just one little teeny piece
you're on fire you're crying it's you
know and everything and this guy had to
do two minutes right after he's like so
anyways oh that a bar I love it I think
we did it three times I might try to
bring that back once but listen why they
turn hot wings into a team oh yeah
that's my friend Sean Mays yeah yeah I
congratulate him that's amazing yes that
just goes to show you you never know you
were on you were on hot ones I forgot
about that and that you were sweating so
how bad was that last the last couple of
them one through six ain't dick right
what got his the [ __ ] with me I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like everybody else raw
[ __ ] weak in somewhere i'ma tell you
the truth just so you know I watched who
was on there before me and I watched
their episodes and I watched their
reactions but nobody's reaction bothered
me more than DJ Khalid oh god because
his Ali Baba trying to be [ __ ] Fat
Joe you know if he talks are have been
the whole thing he's around a lot of
chicken you know I'm saying
yeah IRA but you're swinging with the
brothers you gotta be used to eat that
chicken you can't show up with you know
then you never seen collard greens with
hummus next door
so I'm not trying to be racist or
anything but think about it [ __ ] tell
you
DJ Khalid after like five kid not even
five I think he quit after like lopunny
brother yeah so my mind I'm like if a
[ __ ] black dude if a guy who's trying
to be black as if I'm walking around
trying to be [ __ ] black I would have
snorted those [ __ ] way yeah so will
he tap that for I was like I'm dead but
one is flavorful like two three four
once you get to six yeah it's whenever
that where there's one that just yeah
it's like taking a little bit too much
wasabi mmm it's like taking a little bit
dipping that egg rolling for the mustard
a little bit too much and you put it in
your mouth and you feel like this I give
you it's like plastic surgery you
wouldn't be went through like 20 napkins
you just can't believe that you did that
to yourself that's what it is you do
need milk or ice cream but I wasn't
prepared I should have brought like
Booch I did bring my oh yeah that was
cool that you probably cheese that's
right just in case mm-hmm but it was
fine because you want me to tell you the
truth nine and telling [ __ ] right it's
only that one it's it's seven and eight
yeah it's that a murder murder murder
and then eight nine or like by the time
you do those three eight nine a more
peppery mm-hmm so it's more flavor and
you're may your mother's been on fire
yeah your mouth it's burn is one my
daughter toys Danny the other day the
hot ones come with cameras you look
daddy you did that you know you did that
cuz I saw you with the sweaty shirt I
found that on YouTube and dog I was a
complete V and sweat yeah me my whole
body it just it just shocks your central
nervous system to go through that but I
still do that to myself once in a while
but not to that level oh you know who
was like who was a psycho on that I
think it was Chong he didn't break a
single tear
he didn't act like any of those wings
had anything on him that or I have a
theory that they just gave him all wings
and he forgot to act you know because
like like we could only get him on the
show if if we didn't sauce the wings up
you know cuz he he was trying to sell
something the whole time was a little
weird but he didn't react at any of
those wings and it made me go I wonder
if they they had some special wings for
him or something I'm sure they didn't
like me but if you look at it's pretty
crazy how he doesn't even flinch
but those hot wings well it's great
because you were saying how like I had
like all the shows that failed and all
that that's true but even when when we
when you went to film it it was like
three cameras in a zoom recorder and
it's turned like this guy had an idea
now it's a TV game show like that like
that it is pretty wild than that I mean
my daughter watch the Jonas Brothers
yeah it was crazy yes he was going in on
it I enjoy it it's a fun show it's a
good interviewer to I think I started
getting weird calls that like really
weak calls from people I grew up with
Wow
saying amen you're [ __ ] great like my
kid sees you are there I [ __ ] like that
that video did a lot of it I think I
think re a lot like when you look at the
steps to what helped me it was those
stories those stories you never know
what it's gonna be in this town until
you do it just make sure you're prepared
and you go out there and you do them and
that's it but I think those stories
those 15 minutes segues on our East
storytelling show helped my career more
than just telling the truth more than a
special one the two shitty specials I
didn't want you know I think people
would like that like raw roughness of
that show that [ __ ] was so perfect hurry
perfect yeah
that show was a perfect show you don't
know what's gonna turn the meter with
some people or you don't know what's
going to complete the circle for some
made it
from me I feel that that story tones
show [ __ ] healed me like I had those
stories in me they were good to Sam
sometimes they pop up when I watch him I
get sad you know what I still have
always so we're having a conversation
they trying to write a piece about
Ralphie and they were referring to video
they got him and they asked them
questions and he said a bunch of [ __ ]
that if you know any comic onee but he
was on pills you know he'd be saying
what help when I did those tapes for you
in 2006 at the House of Blues when I was
saying that I wanted to die
oh yeah yeah yeah you still got those
you should put those there up right now
judge ideas ready to die I think it's
Joe Joe show 11 like I was done yeah
like I was eatin [ __ ] that's the
weekend I went we wouldn't like on
Thursday and I didn't see you guys still
sad right like I was doing 8-ball he was
delivering it to the room the guy had to
come down package and give you those
[ __ ] vicodin Z [ __ ] my friends were
in town I wouldn't go to their hotel and
see them I told him I was busy with Joe
that you ever seen
I was working the UFC I don't work too
[ __ ] I wasn't alone up a storm and
then I was forced to go down sadly to do
this [ __ ] show guys got a camera
[ __ ] that's right to me stupid
[ __ ] questions
and I was done like I just wanted a
quick coke I didn't think it was
possible that's what was going on Aaron
left me like [ __ ] Thursday night we
flew in I basically snorted all night
Thursday Friday Joe did something all
that blue you guys off because I was too
busy in my room getting high when Debbie
the whales
Saturday yeah and Saturday I thought
they finally came out I took a shower I
wasn't that ruled for two days straight
no room service to seat Mike Mandalay
Bay he was mad at her eat the [ __ ]
chocolate bars the refrigerator
the paranoia jerking off and the call
so marriage macam who's witnessing you
don't know what it's like to call this
drug be like 4:00 in the morning he
answers and I'm like I need another one
I'll be there in two minutes
don't go I need to go downstairs and I
know all the security guards you come
right to my room asked me if I wanted to
come down package for sleeping pills and
to vicodins to purchase names annex I
need the whole [ __ ] thing we think
it'll feel like the morning hello what
do you think is gonna come out of your
mouth in the morning you have not a
stitch of happiness in your life all the
dopamine has been taken out of your
brain I was on a roll for two days the
things I said on those tapes like we'll
just I always think about that night
that was the darkest time of my life
that last year before I quit coke oh oh
isn't that crazy made it out of that how
insane is that job I mean I even thought
you were a goner when during those times
I mean you when you thought you were
dying and stuff like like I was like oh
man he's only gonna last a couple months
like we all I kind of thought that I had
because you you sold it so well it
wasn't I sold it so well it was what I
was basically [ __ ] going through yeah
my campaign so I did a big movie I hope
I look for Rogen on the road longest guy
right I do spots at the store and this
is it this is my life Herbie there's a
movie in this town people call him up
people invite him to dinner you go to
meetings
I got nothing I got one meeting with Tom
Hanks who told me I was funny or
something like that and said he call me
and I never heard them again really yeah
and Windows Tom Hanks
it's like to be at a bar in Houston yeah
like when that movie came out I was in
Houston and I actually went to see it
with the University of Houston football
team and the Texans we all went to a
private screening in Houston and then I
do like a QA l came to the show and
while I'm at the show that night I'm
[ __ ] coked up and I'm at the old
Houston last doc I'm favorite [ __ ]
bar in the world ringing with Pete with
drinking Yeager's remember we were
[ __ ] going to bathroom ago blow and
Joan was talking to broads he don't see
nothing this is 20 [ __ ] years ago
this is this how long was all the kids
read bad and what the [ __ ] we talked
about I got a call from this guy rest in
peace bill do commit know something do
commit it was a private call number I
was the last one together self alright
so I don't know what a private call was
so I can answer it's like hey it's a
dokument how you though I know good you
know congratulations on the movie cuz
Guddu comin wasn't Groundhog Day
oh he's not Tom Hanks mm-hmm no let's
bail America it's Bill Murray but he did
something with Tom Hanks big was
something he was I just got a call from
my friend of mine Tom Hanks you know the
name I go yeah and at that time I was
just finished boycotting him yeah cuz
the one about the AIDS at the so he came
back with Madonna and Rosie O'Donnell in
the baseball movie yeah then I get
moving I never saw his Gump and then
it's probably two movies because he was
on off he was on 8686 down for two or
three years
crying the [ __ ] the Oscars going up
then crying like you know people he ever
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the ass
comics so yeah I got to meet Tom Hanks
at Sony and that's awesome what one
should ask me a few questions for them
like oh my god I'm gonna go home we got
like an offer for like a million dollars
not that I even call the receptionist
sent the gift thank you for lunch
I never nothing
god I want to know what happened in that
conversation wouldn't you love a copy of
that conversation so Joey tell me about
yourself
what do you remember what you talked
about maybe you freaked him out maybe
poor Tom Hanks you asked me about
whatever he said he had read an
interview that I had been in prison what
I had what did I do
oh there we go how did I feel no no but
he was like really it was you ever do
research that's what he was doing he was
just doing research and he asked me a
bunch of questions he's lonely we talked
about the time he's thrown for a little
bit isn't misty still crazy you know
stuff like that you know he was really
nice it was like an hour he sat down
with me and like an office and they
brought that regular Sony lunch the ones
they make for the executives I don't
know what it was I had a choice like
Salsbury stay right mushroom soup or
something I don't know what to expect
I wanna see the timeframe now to see
what role that he might have been in
research yeah let's see was of your own
yeah we're gonna find out that he's a
castaway
I'm not even anywhere near that but I
can't imagine how tough it is being in
this town
and thinking all this is gonna happen
this is gonna happen and it just it just
doesn't no wonder people go crazy it
doesn't happen because you don't make it
happen and that's what makes people go
crazy if they don't even give it a shot
at Megan
and they you know it's really weird for
gallic me I I know who I am
I'm 57 years old this charade is over
look at me the only role I'm good for
his grandpa from the Munsters me if they
remake the Munsters grandpa ho how
[ __ ] grandpa I'm gonna be the best
grandfather ever was on the Munsters all
right beside that look at me I got maybe
another two years on stage before I fall
off the [ __ ] stage I'm old I can't
walk around I can't see right
you know I'm free you'd be a good
landlord for a Three's Company rebuild
I'm free right now how much free is a
whistle oh wow Lawrence what's let us
get it that free burn I'm a free bird
you can't get mad at what I say because
you can't take nothing from me I go to
the comedy store which is my church and
I'm a Mitchie Shore protege I'm exactly
what she wanted you to do on stage to be
a wild man and not care you know that
you know there was a time when she
didn't want the industry in there she
threw them out you know that right I'd
love that she paid them she made them
pay for tickets the industry knew they
weren't invited the Comedy Store she
said make you comics a creepy and it
does all of a sudden like showcases oh
hi how are you
you people never spoke in those days
when you went to the comedy store and
there was an asterisk next to your name
that means somebody was coming to see
you and four people would actually come
down there to wait to see who was coming
to see you and as soon as two guys these
people would never say hello to you
don't never talk to you
yeah don't never cheer for you you've
asked them for Gazin they've told you
now while those two people are there
they'll come up you're lonely
how you doing buddy great to see you and
all something they just and that you're
like red banner this is Lee Lee this is
redneck oh yeah yeah yeah maybe I should
send you a tape and you're in
side's fracture because this is your
meeting and this is [ __ ] who's
never said how old are you in this whole
[ __ ] life now in front of those
agents is being cool to you right
so Mitzi didn't like all that [ __ ] so
she's to say it makes people creepy I
agree so she would make them pay and
take the asterisk that I talked to about
take the Astor's now I can't even
mention the names of the people I guess
some what's still around that would show
up on those nights and be your buddy and
buy you a drink
and cotton on your company bring scripts
you have no idea
I can mention names to you that your
head would blow up happened to me once
being here I got a script for you oh
yeah I think Joey be great for this it's
the word just give it back no listen the
CAA and they'll take care of the rest
but i don't know i love i used to
torture rogas people Rogen people are
the best ones that call you and ask you
for his number and you're like yeah it's
number hold on grab a pen make them hold
and then look like that partner going
okay I'm waiting yeah Joey you know we
love you right yeah we just want Rogen's
number cuz we have a gig for him and you
want to see what he thinks I'm again
look grab a pen sure take your time all
right you ready 3 108 8 8 8 8 8 that's
William what about his personal I can't
give me that call Sussman management out
of New York
I'll call William Morris have a good day
like just hang up on it yeah you think
about the Planned Parenthood number
I had a half a [ __ ] fact producer
called me about a month ago he didn't
even call me I've known this guy for 25
years always been a sweetheart of it I
had never really done business with him
he's always doing stupid shows so
there's no reason for me that you know
like I don't talk to him whatever he's
asked me about it to do a couple of his
shows and I've always told him I'm busy
on the road that week about a month ago
I don't know any Facebook's me which
really bothers me because hey man I need
a big favor from you know we missed out
on this casting notice and we need a guy
in two days to fill the host position
I think it'll pay $15,000 is there any
way you'd give me Rogen's info and I go
I'm going to tell you two pieces of
advice
first of all Rogan doesn't want to do
anything before you even call them and
number two I am DBM you know your
producer why are you making this [ __ ]
email nothing bothered me more than that
that somebody who says they're a film
producer and he is is a TV show little
time producer doesn't IMDB somebody so
again he hits me back Wow we're not
gonna have time is there any way I can
get his number for me and I solicit
doctors agent Lee and then they said to
me we called CAA 10 times double you'll
call us back about Joe Rogan there they
go if you're this [ __ ] stupid I can't
let him do business with you he's the
WME so you never even looked you just I
just caught you the lie I just caught
you with a line why would you try to
[ __ ] light aanchal James I'm like why
would you don't do it don't do it don't
do it do you wanna do it or whatever
people
I see you coming at me a mile away it's
your small time I I see how the Facebook
messages start I have these guys that
you don't hear from them every six
months they start with hey how you doing
hey what's going on with the podcast we
could do lunch nope do lunch I'll do
lunch I don't know what I'm late lunch
no [ __ ] idea I have no idea I cants
not lock you in for lunch I don't know
what I'm gonna do tomorrow what happens
one thing that Rogen definitely has
taught me that my favorite thing that
Rogen's taught me is just to ignore
everything you know what I mean you'll
talk to the people you love like y'all
talk I'll answer the phone of Joey cause
but 90 at 9:00 a person of the other
people that call nope you're not getting
any response for me you know but uh he I
always like thought it that's so rude
you know people are texting you or
telling you it for that but yeah even
it's too much for that position of you
know I went to Vegas last weekend I get
home but also I get home but I got 23
text messages because it doesn't come on
my phone till I get home to a certain
area then a bunch of text message you
should have seen these text messages
that I get like I don't get a lot of
them I guarantee that treat the house
cuz there's text messages that come on
my iPad that I don't get on my iPhone
yeah I will put up my [ __ ] iPad and
I'll have 10 text messages are there
from I don't even know how these pin
them are you in town what type of reply
like I'm gonna say yes oh no yeah you're
never gonna get up what's the worst the
worst yeah if you if you look at your
own text history and you don't have a
conversation going already you have to
say hey this is Bob what's going on are
you in town you know I have so many of
those I I've missed opportunities I bet
I would wonder if like any of those are
important like oh dude that's uh you
know elites that's David Lee Roth I
can't believe he texted me but you know
I'm sure that's not gonna be somebody
like that but half these people who are
they
I'm nowhere near any of either
your levels but every three months
someone just gets my phone number
somehow and it's scary yeah text me or
call me and I'll be the one do something
I'm out do you not see how this is kind
of scary do you respond to those no
let's just get scary I've I blocked
their number sometimes but no how do you
not see that this is kind of creepy if I
don't know your number first of all
you're in no danger me because no danger
may pick up the phone you have no danger
and texting you have no danger getting a
hold of me I'm telling you because it's
very weird that's why I called you today
when I text you oh yeah yeah my hearing
aids went into that system mm-hmm I'm
getting text messages I just got a Merry
Christmas two weeks ago February 26 late
your hearing aid it's connected to your
phone yeah that's awesome you want to
get one man that's been his [ __ ] and
yeah like somebody called me on my
wife's phone I was like my niece wants
to talk to you I know they couldn't
understand that it's so weird that was a
regular iPhone now I couldn't hear if I
didn't have the the system connected
through my phone I hate it but it's
through my phone cuz it's [ __ ] up a
lot of [ __ ] but I'd rather hear than
hear from them do you know I'm saying
like for a while there bro people were
talking I call J time just like Joey
stuff was going on and then we really we
figured out there was something wrong
with the we left it on autopilot all
right yeah why yeah airplane my airplane
mode something was going on rogue and
told me a couple times he called me I
just wasn't getting fax messages all
over the place
tackle is all over to play I always keep
my [ __ ] in airplane mode because a
podcast usually so there's some times
wherever like oh [ __ ] I've had this on
for six hours you know I hope no one
called me yeah that happens it's great
to be away from your phone though out
having it on the airplane mode I think
do you think we've gone
a little bit too far Your Honor both
tech guys I love tech but I think some
tech has gone a little bit too far like
I yeah I think maybe like the when like
the original iPhones weren't enough like
some like the smart like Smart TVs like
some of the stuff that's going I think
it just waste I think all the digital
assistants have gone too far now like I
have I have Alexa and Google like in all
my appliances now like my TV my vlogs so
like sometimes I'll just be talking and
I have nowhere you hear I don't know
what you're talking about I'm like well
I wasn't talking to you like why are you
listening to me right now that's creepy
why do you have that why honestly
because it's nowadays everything's so
connected where I'm just so you know
like what's the weather what's the
weather my security cameras so like if
something goes off I'd be like you know
show me my security or my TV will just
flip onto my security camera you know
awesome they both of them yeah you your
whole life is being your whole life is
being [ __ ] listening to and invaded
and you know you're you're a communist
you live in economy this environment if
you really think about it you're
supporting a communist environment for
being what for being a yuppie now is
marginal any old is that what it means
that it's more like music and stuff
listen I think about me growing up and
my stepdad getting out of jail in 1969 I
had never gone back again though he died
2006 and he was still a bookmaker he
learned lessons but he wouldn't even let
me talk to him next to a phone that was
hung up do you understand me that was a
paranoia he had and he was right he was
right you know
and now you look at these computers
they're watching when you're jerking off
and you're about to put a bug up your
ass they got you yeah
who's watching you who knows but why
give them more wealth they already know
listen your credit cards in the computer
file guess what what day's gonna come up
what are you creating you bought a
blender in the Ukraine that's just the
way life is
do you see those ring cameras your hack
now yeah and they can talk to you like
finished off yeah yeah Jesus you have no
security what so ever anymore so I don't
add to that millennial image or whatever
I avoid that stuff I don't want somebody
in my house taping you don't know who
the [ __ ] is listen if anybody's
listening wrong maybe there's no reason
for a paranoia but you have to assume
then listen it's like when you walk into
a hotel room in Vegas you have to assume
there's somebody there all watching you
jerk off and stick a finger up your ass
no you think this you think do you think
it's in Vegas all for a fact yeah I know
for a fact it's drove into my psyche
especially after the shooting I know for
a fact that in 1983 a buddy of mine went
to Vegas and walked into a bathroom
stall closed the door behind didn't
wanna coke in the stall real quiet he
was a cop walked out of store washed his
hands and when he walked out two cops
away from they know he had dunk okay Wow
I was cameras in the ceiling I know that
a year or so after that a girl I went to
high school with and very dear friends
with went to Vegas for our honeymoon and
a five oh five year anniversary she took
the TV on at the Poconos in the orbit
porn that was dem on there their wedding
that no Shane suit the hotel by three
million dollars 1988-89
so I'm telling you this is what was
going on thirty years ago what do you
think is going on today you have to
assume when you go to Vegas they're
watching you [ __ ] that checked yeah
they're watching you [ __ ] that hooker
and they're watching you they got you
down they have those scanners you get by
now
like that will show you if there's any
hitting cameras or microphones
it's like radioactive you know really
not react it's an electrical it's an
electrical thing yeah but you the
[ __ ] that you are not you ready I'm
talking about you the [ __ ] being Joe
American it's like when I don't know if
you know this like right now
technology's really weird you know how
they busted the Gambino crime family
they had a snitch that told him that
Paul Castellano spoke mainly in the
kitchen and there was a TV in the
kitchen where they wouldn't where there
would be they would watch when they were
in the kitchen before people come over
and then they'd go turn the TV off what
they did was they knew if there was a TV
so the feds actually D scrambles the TV
and they're sitting there hitting them
and then moving the antenna and they got
cable this is Paul Castellanos house at
Staten Island - for million dollar house
in 1980 what do you think it's worth
today it's a mansion and the [ __ ]
cable don't work but there other rooms
all the TVs worked so they called the
[ __ ] TV repairman only it was an FBI
guy that picked up the phone they won in
this house and they put bugs in now this
is how dumb they were when they had the
bugs and the TV they would they knew
what time they would say Oh Paulie
everything's taken care of with the
sweeper he's coming around three o'clock
today no problem at three o'clock they
shut off the bugs and they and the
sweeper can't pick up the electric for
frequency ha ha
so once the guy would leave they would
turn the bugs back on again
the feds installed the bugs while Paul
Castellano and Tommy Bilotti were in the
room into the TV and Tommy boy is like
hurry up with that thing [ __ ] oh you
know and you're like yeah sure he knows
another you're installing a [ __ ] bug
that's gonna go down a [ __ ] Virginian
they gotta listen to every conversation
in this [ __ ] room that's how they do
a bug then they had they were they were
bugging he would power by with
microphones
you know the microphones
and if I use this rain they'll go two
blocks away to another frequency and
bounce it off that glass and right now
we're in here talking about killing
somebody and they're listening to us
through that [ __ ] class without a
wire without anything that was 30 years
ago what the [ __ ] do you think they're
doing today we just draw on the phone
yeah they just turn on violence turn on
cameras have we did everything I don't
know that's why I put the fall in the
office at night I put the follow the
officer littel here with my family
chatter ease they don't have to hear my
family Chad as I tell my wife to put
hers on the charger in our office will
fall free in the [ __ ] house and it's
not paranoia it's just you know they
listen to you're watching it how much
are you going to let them how much
information that you gonna give them
about yourself online every time you
sign up for another stupid website do
you really need then to send you peanut
butter online do you really need peanut
butter you got traded joke down the
corner but you want a special peanut
butter on it later now you have to tell
them like what you give me three things
from your life so they can ask you your
first dog Fifi your first girlfriend's
name Amelia now they know everything
yeah - they put it together with all
that [ __ ] you know so the more things
you sign up for go ahead look at me
Paris go the more [ __ ] you open up the
more [ __ ] they got on you and then I'm
not talking I won't sell drugs
I don't waddle I don't do dick you can
listen to my phone lines all you want
you're gonna hear the most boring
conversation you're gonna hear
conversation me and my 50 year old
friends complaining about how tired we
are having expressions we got a drink a
day and you hear me and Tripoli or me
and you or me and you that's it
there's no I don't need that dalian have
women that I talk to that like whack off
you can listen to me all day it's the
most boring is [ __ ] in the world but I
think your house know and they told you
15 times Alexa goes right to the [ __ ]
double this house these little company
so we thought you [ __ ] little Chinese
girl man
the blades to camera that you think
you're watching the bow with they're
watching you when you got a doggy style
bad boy [ __ ] trouble over trouble
looking red bad over there [ __ ] them
well Chinese girls and she's Korean or
hey I would have never read like a
Chinese like I said yes to it those
Asian people they the dogs are they the
bat and that's how this [ __ ] thing
started when I say Asian so nobody gets
offended mmm that's how you ever go to
Chinatown the ship that hangs from the
windows there's a dad you even know what
the [ __ ] yeah and go to China that's
where you see the real good [ __ ] you
know I gotta [ __ ] a chicken's feet for
hard-ons they'll eat anything for honor
and Chinese people if you tell them
little piece of [ __ ] on bread we'll get
your dick hard
you'll see Chinese people eat and dick
on bread that's what they do they
there's a soup that's made out of both
walls that's like $2,000 that's one
night it gives you the puts you dick
like in magical places you go to the
restaurant right now you see a bunch of
[ __ ] Chinese people playing and a
bunch of old people drinking the soup
looking at they all wives like I'm gonna
give it to you tonight
you know it's [ __ ] not oh the [ __ ]
knows I don't even know anymore I'm just
happy to be doing what I'm doing it's
all insulin who the [ __ ] knows in two
weeks you might be walking around with
spacesuits down here yeah I know you
have to think that way how far this
could go you imagine they have to close
Disneyland this door has to shut the
hell for a couple weeks how come I can't
leo because in Japan oh they should
definitely yeah that's care that's
cancer they just have enough stuff you
better move that over the [ __ ] Australia
by the [ __ ] raise there yeah they're
canceling all day like the electronic
shows and stuff like that all the trade
shows and and I guess there's the
company that makes I phone cameras I
guess they've been shut down so they're
not gonna happen you know all the new
iPhones are probably gonna be delayed
this year they're just losing money left
and right
well did you get but it was like the
AIDS scare in the eighties when we were
scared of mosquitoes remember that when
we were like every news channel was like
dude there's there's mosquitoes with
AIDS and if they bite you you're gonna
have AIDS there was points time where we
everyone was scared of getting mosquito
bite so everyone had like that you can
buy mosquito repellent at stores they
were sold out everywhere kind of like
how hand sanitizers sold out everywhere
right now you know it's like everyone
was putting off all over them just so
they wouldn't get AIDS mosquitoes but it
really is crazy how I went that
walgreens did that again some completely
off-color
and while I was there people are like is
any more answer ties and then people had
masks coming cuz these people had all
the we paranoid night listen I
understand it
I get it I get it you know and
especially who would wanted sinning
whatever you know our friend Jimmy shoe
burrs in Korea to that she's shoot the
TV show is he shooting a Korean show and
he's a white guy on our American show
that shoots in Korean Wow in quarantine
they only got the cancellation noticing
me I would have had them waiting for the
plane with a little master it was
waiting for me to come out mr. Diaz
really about they would have been no mr.
Diaz I'm gonna put my company over there
I would have sent him to Korea yeah he
even told me Jimmy she wasn't Anya
they even got me a first-class ticket
like a bro they're giving you money to
fly that man go go go look up a flight
for curry it said 102 $22 really
first-class and back the [ __ ] is gonna
fly to Korea today you're crazy
$100 right now look at the prices that
[ __ ] it's dropping plane prices are
dropping they know people gonna go you
know what this is how we're gonna spread
is in these planes one person per plane
and that's it I gotta fly to New York
next week you don't think I'm [ __ ]
nervous you want me to look you in the
eye and tell you I'm not nervous I've
been flying a lot too last couple weeks
it sucks
I do but internationally do I though
this mother yeah but I mean I luckily
right before all this half
and I had bought these really nice masks
with the little air filters and them and
stuff like that because my girlfriend's
allergies are so bad that she's been
miserable so I was like you know what my
buyer one of these cool Asian masks and
literally the week after this
coronavirus start coming out and now you
can't get these masks they're like
backordered for months now to get them
Dave you noticed that they're all the
hospitals are running out of these masks
because everyone keeps on buying them
but uh it's ridiculous this saying not
to buy them because right hospital care
workers need up like that yeah amen we
gotta be cautious to how you you know
how do you office up the Icehouse ball
no they the Icehouse solder comedy club
to the the Laker owners you know the the
family of the Lakers and so when that
happened
they're pretty much well we have to set
you know empty out this place and I gave
me an excuse to get out of there I've
been there for like nine years eight
years and you know it's now have an
office down the street from my house so
it's way easier you know it's it's a big
use the office it's probably like maybe
four times bigger than this glad do
today of the day I could but it would be
a small little room but that's an that's
a cool thing about it it's it's a
storefront so like if I didn't want to
do podcast I can make it a taco shop the
next day you know or a little stand-up
comedy club it's it's actually a retail
alone which is a little old comedy
that's right
get his used tray over there have you
watched his new show you're on it right
yeah yeah yeah yeah I love that man
because this is awesome for that he's so
like the first episode fluffy was it
fluffy yeah said great man fluffy is so
cool like his Volkswagens all his
Volkswagens he has I'm so jealous of
that it really is amazing what he's done
with his life and yeah and he's as
humble as they Tom he's so funny just
sweet as they come you know the Spanish
comics [ __ ] hey them like the
old-school Mexicans really yeah you know
why I think just you know jealous but
just no jealousies isn't a lot of
[ __ ] you know but
it's just weird our life is you know
when you're when you're a lad on top
people still take shots idea to stuff
like that so it's uh and I see it on his
face and his feelings get hurt you know
it's uh it's tough when your family has
never seen the money you've amassed and
everybody's waiting for their part you
like well the [ __ ] were you I'm the one
that has to kind of plan go to Australia
to pick up this envelope but uh it's
really weird it's a really weird feeling
so it just he's humbled you know well
you know though yeah his his compound
look badass though I was I was raised in
one of those Volkswagen buses and you
know that like the big bus and he has
like maybe a hundred of those buses
every single color there's one that's a
fish tank the whole bus has just been
made into a fish tank it's an investment
it's a way he's a collector yeah and you
got a love for that that's that's a
beautiful place what would you if you
were crazy crazy rich what would you
have any collections of any kind like
what would be in your huge warehouse at
this age cats just cats I would like to
learn to grow like if I move some land
what's the dirt so I learned how to grow
vegetables I see what my wife has done
the last couple years and she's grown a
ton of [ __ ] back there that's good too
tomatoes yeah peppers you know I think
that's important to know like I think I
mean I grew up always having a garden
you know in Ohio I'd really like to
learn how to do that now I always sit
there in one like I don't have a hobby
out of the track thing in this yeah I
lift weights and yeah I go to boxing
class and [ __ ] jukebox and that's not
a hobby like you know what I really I'm
thinking of doing again collecting
coins coins yeah like just go to a coin
shop buy those books and you fill up
those pants yeah their little slot so
that makes you look for those patties
that's why the other day my wife went to
my wife's got a jar filled you know I
had to pick up the check I know let's
not take it down there let's empty it
and go through those pennies because
that's what those companies do there's
no money or Coinstar wait any stylers
and take your change
they take your chains because you're
making mistakes yeah
those silver dollars that 1943 penny
that's what the million dollars the
copper penny all that [ __ ] you just
drawn in there that's how they make that
money they don't make them money buy you
troll [ __ ] money in that thing and
then we're giving you a dollar I thought
that money their real money is my taking
them the coins and award something and
they get what they're worth think about
that oh yeah I've always thought that so
when I was a kid and I was really
insecure before I was learning the
language there was a short time but
that's what I did
I collected pennies I had the [ __ ]
magnifying glass by the way I gotta tell
you guys a story [ __ ] calm as a
[ __ ]
so by the year ago I would take
weekend's a little wee containers when
they're finished and I would put holes
in the towel and free that we that's and
I just feed him weed for like four days
I gotta take a [ __ ] in my backyard I
open up my backdoor I fly would come in
the back door is locked so they can't
get out of get in so I stalk him I just
locked the door boom I get another fly
take his one wing off throws it and then
I'd feed him look it's a week let us out
let us sound I must have got about six
flies took their wings off about their
wings depending how I felt that day
little Dirty Bastard
my hands a thousand times and I'd put
him in the [ __ ] thing and I'd put
weed in there well [ __ ] they were
getting stronger and stronger there from
time to time I put like a gummy bear in
there like a CBD gummy bear like I was
just developing these flies but you
savages right it's just boss just balls
out so one day I took these flies and I
just drew him out into the wilderness
just a saying they didn't know where
they were they landed on my patio floor
just looking at me like what wingless we
don't know nothing Lau's about a six
months ago beyond that I'm sitting there
and I hear like this buzzin like there's
a fly in my room I look over this
[ __ ] was a gigantic Oh like a
horsefly
he was so big he was having a hard time
flying like he couldn't even fly he
hopped but he would hop by three feet so
I will no long way what does [ __ ] is
that is because I got spiders too every
once awhile you'll see a spider that's a
big [ __ ] spider when I got closer it
was a THC flies had got all business I
[ __ ] up still he was making a [ __ ]
different fly noise it was like mm-hmm
so I clocked him and he fell but I lost
them I couldn't stamp and kill him
[ __ ] a half hour lay them on the
computer and he just lands on the desert
he's coming back together so I tried to
fling him off the desk to step on I'm
gonna get he disappeared
and then from time to time I take a [ __ ]
and take a little scoop of this [ __ ] and
put them there once a week just leave my
[ __ ] I have these flies under experiment
torture me when I was a kid I took daddy
longlegs and I took off it took all
their legs off and then they're just
like a little ball and they couldn't
just stomp on anthills I hate I hate but
have you seen that like they pour metal
down the inhale out like see how far
down like
pretty cool it's pretty cool I like I
[ __ ] I'm one time I was in Miami
Florida must have been eight years old
and I was helping my godfather rake
leaves he had this huge like [ __ ]
property with every type of tree papaya
mom goes avocados and I was raking
leaves and he had the garbage can and he
goes don't put your hand in there let me
go get your gloves I'm like [ __ ] you I
put my hand in there and when I pulled
them out both my hands were covered with
red bee oh I thought it bite me if you
ever saw me fall apart like a little
[ __ ] that was a death wish that was up
video I just drive red handle it like I
read and it got me so hard but I just
passed out I thought I was gonna die and
I passed out he came out white there
told me it won't be up there I took the
to be what is wrong with you get up you
[ __ ] a little flag what's wrong with
you rather than cube I got bit by a
scorpion I'm saying like [ __ ] like that
I lived you'll be fine I had blood
everywhere
Yeah right ant suck hell with that dog
both hands I was maybe eight whatever
yeah good [ __ ] yeah but the Flies end
well those flies came back to get me
he's still in your office yes you gotta
find it he's gonna be a maggot dogs
whining he grew into another fly's ass
would be weird that he warp you gotta
see the size of this [ __ ] thing house
and it has to be dead flies and [ __ ]
everywhere what happened was a [ __ ]
dead possum fell into the war uh so we
started getting flies in the house they
had to come and take the dead possum
alcohol smoke terrible for a week I was
in a hotel room one night I had to sit
there by myself and kill each fly one by
one I was sweeping them into the
backyard I just stood there they were
all gathered by the window and they get
[ __ ] you see how they get my glasses
kill them by the dozens bah bah bah and
they would circle a room but I'd be
sitting there I don't use a flyswatter
I use a drug a jigsaw puzzle book
they're perfect
those baggy puzzles you know six across
yeah yeah that type of [ __ ] [ __ ]
possums so there was a possum we have a
lot of possums where I live and there
was one time I was going out to my car
and there was a possum like a smaller
possum like a baby and he was just
laying right in front of my car and I
and I was like late to a spot so I
called Janis my girlfriend I was like
hey Janis there's a possum in the
driveway can you like throw it away
here's something I think it's dead and
she and she cuz I she text me back and
she's holding it like a baby and she
goes I think it's sick and I'm like wait
do you have the possum in our house she
goes yeah he's still breathing and then
my friend goes and he goes he wasn't
dead you know they play possum oh my god
I'm surprised you still live there after
your rats oh don't get me started on my
rats how are they God oh yeah the rats
are gone
we found a hole the size of a nickel in
my friend my neighbors screen door so
they were coming through this tiny tiny
hole through into my neighbor's house
going underneath his sink underneath her
house coming out from underneath my sink
so it was all from this one little teeny
hole and so yeah thank God we found it
now no problems well they were big they
were probably about the smaller footage
yeah and the gross thing is when we
found him dead they were so bloated that
they'd look like a small chihuahua I
mean that's how big they were because
they were so bloated but and then I had
my girlfriend take it out to the
trashcan one split open and just maggots
came pouring out of it it was yeah I
think about it all the time so [ __ ]
just lay some swell up so yeah I think
when you just when they die that's like
what happened is they they sat like well
we I started smelling that death smell
and then I went underneath the sink and
one of my traps had killed it but I
thought I already got rid of the rat and
this is like its mom or something like
that it had killed it it had been in
there for like a week and it just being
in the week underneath my sink I just
made it
like maggots started growing inside of
it and was so inflated because the
maggot
inside of it I couldn't I thank God for
my girlfriend cuz I could not have done
anything with I would had to hire
somebody just come in to take it away
cats cats cats cats cats cats cats cats
a cat says oh my god them cats cats cats
I hate [ __ ] mice cats cats cats I
hate [ __ ] rats cats cats cats I don't
want to see it but listen I got two cats
across the street from my house that had
been out there my professional hunters
yesterday me and my wife watched the one
little black-and-white one sitting up
there and the white one came out and sat
over here to get Sun in front of them he
said oh you're my [ __ ] vision and he
got around and sat around and went back
for his spot then this cat bit of a bag
they're the cutest couple but those two
cats lived right across the street and I
can't tell you how many nights I'm
coming home from the Comi store and I'll
see the one black-and-white one dragging
a six-foot rat mm-hmm and he's still
half alive but she squashed his [ __ ]
head they are the best husbands and they
are there's evil and lets him out at
night listen you know one of mice just
get some cats let them pee little around
it's gonna smell for a week but after
that everything goes away we don't have
a mouse Brock if I see a mouse
I moved the next day yeah yeah that's I
win and we didn't grow up with rats in
Ohio we grew up with mice but none of my
family has had know how they came in
December for a week yeah I got cold out
yeah I can live with that yeah I can
live I get it it's called now you're
homeless I'm Christian
you wanna come in you're never staying
for a week yeah but once you stop
reproducing in my [ __ ] Rogan told me
once that he could have to be home on a
certain day because the people will come
and turn fumigators
his ceiling you know what are you
talking about
that's a [ __ ] no well
rats I can see the ghetto having rats
you have ratcheted oh my god I can hear
wrestling up there fighting how can you
sleep with that I'll try no they gotta
go to Rogen's once a [ __ ] week and
said traps there's bats up there is that
crazy
like the like no matter how what kind of
house you have if you live in Los
Angeles you have to deal with these
creatures like the ceiling up the house
is a business out here where you have to
go to your somebody comes to your house
once a month looks at every single crack
and corner of your house to make sure
that there's not a way a rodent can get
in there or a bat or a paw sign of bad
in my house when I was a kid
bat yeah I lived in I lived in the
suburbs and fluid one a way to get
something to come to the house like that
scene from the office it was terrified
someone I was a little kid I was like
six or seven they came and I got it I
don't know I just remember we had a we
had a our first floor was a circle and I
just remember flying all the way around
and someone came in with a bat or not
they got it but you probably why am i
that's why in the way that's why you
have four Tati
anyway where are you this weekend my
brother I'm gonna be bad boy thinks yeah
I'm gonna be in a we're going to we have
kill Tony and Ventura and then we also
are going to Washington we have a bunch
of dates
Boston's coming back up even though
we're just in Swansea last week and
Leeds enough skanks South we're gonna be
in Houston coming up and that's gonna be
like there seems like a lot of fun it's
gonna be a lot of fun but you know I've
been to all the skank fests and they
party so I'm just
I'm hoping the the Houston you know I
could still win a bunch of Houston cops
to be there and stuff you know because
they're a little strict in Houston you
know when it comes to partying and we
were having it at the compound right at
that place yeah yeah that secret group
yeah so that should be fine you can stay
themselves yeah yeah that's a blast yeah
I love that that what a great club
that's recon West they really don't like
the job those guys and I have commend
them and
they hip they get it and they're in you
know and that's why they door was
getting passed down there they gather
than they're in yeah so I can't wait for
all that that's good probably shows you
doing the podcast and stand for the scam
fest yeah I think we're doing I usually
do a death squad show there and then we
usually do a kill Tony show and then a
couple comedy shows usually it's they
it's so great doing a comedy festival
you know the like that because it's all
just you don't have to do any of these
[ __ ] shows it's all just cool shows
you know with cool comics in all the way
I look at it we do a comedy festival
Ritu's they had the comedy story yeah
really you know I mean every Tuesday
that's the bus that your favorite day
their comedy story it's not my favorite
it's the one I'm forced to go right when
you're in the Mafia you have to come in
one night a week May you do is pay your
respects it's Tuesday night at the store
that's what it became yeah Tuesday that
is the night before Thanksgiving for
comics we leave on Wednesday we start
leaving on Thursday Tuesday night is
Thanksgiving but the night before
Thanksgiving at the store you go down
there you see Whitney Cummings Eliza
with the dog mold of Moshe kasher
I see you I see the black kid that runs
at Moses who I loved it that I asked a I
see a boy and we were just talking about
that's uh he's a savage you know the
white kid ninh gentleman
Jeremiah Watkins I see Ali Wong
sometimes I see Bell / sometimes I see
everybody I see Ron while at the bar in
the back drinking a [ __ ] garden he's a
man right now yeah so where else would I
want to be on a Tuesday night yeah you
know it's it's gonna be interesting when
they do a show for Netflix you know what
how it's gonna compare to the store
people coming to the store from other
countries to feel the experience in the
store trust me I'm telling I see I see I
see the t-shirts
I heard about the number of t-shirts
they're selling now it's a completely
different world it's corporate it's
really hard to explain to people with
the Comedy Store it's become Mitzi
Shores not there there's a little
corporate but I pay you what's there
more now that wasn't before how mr.
comics love each other yeah
people hang there come on it's hanging
hang will come as you stand there hang
they hate now comics hang there and see
people and hug people you know I bet I
can brought about by G affalo I like it
mahogany I tell my love I've known you
since you were a kid now you [ __ ] I
knew bad geometry is how many years I
got bad [ __ ] I thought it might be
baby Benji sad though mm-hmm I know
these guys when they were kids when I
first met them there were kids and now
I'm seeing them do great things what's
great things down at the store at 8:45
and they bring him me up and then I get
off when I bring off Justin Martindale
and I give him the hog and I'm back
there cheering fam there's a love at the
Comedy Store that is incorporate you
know and that's what that's what people
pay if I had ticket for this morning the
show was already sold out and guess what
there was no lineup that's when you have
to respect something when there's low
lineup and the shows are already so
ridiculous I wanted to see what time my
spot was because I definitely know I got
a 925 but they ever saying like that
that's how crazy it is that Tuesday
night the [ __ ] there was no lineup
out and already he said sold out for
Tuesday and Thursday like wow wow this
is [ __ ] great so but it's great to
see what you're doing
it's guys seeing you all and I'm happy
what's maybe a little podcast network is
still des koala des part yeah we're
doing David Lucas and Williams podcasts
doing kill Tony doing desk wide
chronicles once in a while but yeah it's
all the same thing just walk oh well it
cools would stand up but I'll be there
one fright I need to make that I need
I think that's a good idea put my video
games Golden Tickets to come and sit
yeah watch the show from the Burbank
area yeah cuz I love to be a part of
that laughter boy Friday at 9:00 yeah
the tool but I want to see the trouble
with the freight stick you have to go up
and do like professionals have to do
three minutes and I would be a
bothersome I miss you yeah I miss you
too guys I mean that the last couple
years the original clique has been
getting involved in their own things and
that's great to see but anything also
toe that we we miss each other I got a
really emotional call from rogue in the
air night well we need to all get
together so yeah I'm take a week and I'm
longer rolling broken yeah I'm doing a
couple dates on this tour just to break
it up you know yeah just to add a little
dimension to my life and I already got
the dates pick that up pop those Donuts
I'm going to Texas on my own when I'm
going to Austin on my own El Paso
yeah I'm pretty lucky that let's see
like I hope that this disease doesn't
spread and you're not allowed to fly it
looks like Lee's driving the [ __ ]
rental you could drive early you have no
Charlie tickets yeah well he just got
one under way to read I did get one out
[ __ ] I forgot about that
I paid off he had to pay an attorney who
was it that you were sleeping while you
were driving or no good morning and it
was a it was one of the back roads
Rutgers was 65 225 when it doesn't tell
you then they were waiting there for me
Oh speech rapping [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and now let me talk to you
about the sponsors all right I want to
thank ride Brian Redman I want to thank
the [ __ ]
most importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] as far as this Thursday's
concerned listen man New York City put a
state of emergency I don't know if we're
gonna do this y'all know if I'm getting
flown in for the movie so I'll be tell
you keep you posted on Twitter and
Facebook but Santa Barbara never fear
Uncle Joe is here and he ain't queer
he's
and the 27th of March on a [ __ ]
Friday night get your tickets at
Arlington Peter calm right now and
that's it and that's that my heart goes
out to the nation we don't know what's
going on with this coronavirus my heart
goes out to the world I don't know
what's going you know I'm sitting here
I'm supposed to go to New York and shoot
this film we don't know
I got levity on Thursday night I was
long excited to go up to Nayak and get
that [ __ ] pizza right on the [ __ ]
corner there by the hotel I wasn't
spending the night I was just going up
there and if they got us up in New York
but anyway I'll keep you guys posted
post and have a good Monday sling some
dick tell the coronavirus to suck your
dick you're prepared you understand me
you're taking your vitamin C you're
getting some vitamin B and don't let
people breathing you don't need to do
big you understand me like if you don't
want to come to the show Thursday I get
it you don't want to come get a fat [ __ ]
you don't know why I'm coming I'm comes
on a plane I might be a [ __ ] Corona
holder you know I'm saying you don't
[ __ ] know so mind your business don't
let people breathe on you smoke by
yourself
and have a good day in a good week I'll
see you [ __ ] Wednesday
tip-top [ __ ] Magoo have a great
day love you